i really loved your work
on the pixar movies and they've been
talking about doing these pixar shorts
uh like with monsters at work and other
things are you and
are you doing any of these disney plush
shorts with monsters
well justine it's not a short it's a
series
it's a television it's a series and john
goodman and i
are sully and mike um the this
uh shows um time-wise starts six months
after monsters inc uh ended
so now we're on the laugh floor and
they've created all of these new young
great characters
with some great voice actors and and and
john and i
are reprising our parts and i tell you
it's
you know 20 years since and that movie
looked amazing 20 years ago it's coming
up to the 20th anniversary
um uh i believe in september
uh and um it's
it's fantastic looking and it's
hilarious and we're having a lot of fun
doing it
you're actually recording that now yeah
we've done a bunch
we've been on a break because of the the
pandemic
um but some i was able to do at home
and some i was able to do in a very
deserted uh studio
uh out in burbank to be the only one on
the lot was a little weird
um but yeah we're progressing and i
don't know when they're gonna start
but uh i promise you they're really good
are they
like 20-minute episodes are they
10-minute episodes like do you know what
no they're they're they're full-length
uh summer half hour
um it's hard to tell when you're just
you know reading you know
but they're full scripts and um
and it's a continuing story so i think
it's it's uh
it's really gonna be fun